OK, so there's this provocative
new essay making the rounds, and
it basically puts a name to
something a lot of people have
been noticing, a really sudden,
really dramatic shift in how
American patriotism is being
talked about.
So we're going to break down its
central argument piece by piece.
The essay kicks off with this
zinger of a line.
Right away, it sets this sharp,
analytical tone.
It's basically telling us that
what we're about to look at
isn't just a simple change of
opinion, but more like a
performance, a show with a
hidden motive.
And this is the core puzzle,
right?
The essay points out that, I
mean, just a little while ago,
it felt like a lot of the
mainstream conversation was
about framing America's founding
as, you know, a criminal
project.
And now, all of a sudden, that
same culture seems to be
wrapping itself in patriotic
language again.
So the source asks, what is
behind this sudden reversal.
The essay actually has a name
for this feeling patriotic
whiplash.
It contrasts the very recent
past, where criticizing
historical figures and
institutions was pretty common,
with this sudden new embrace of
phrases like our Republic and
the promise of America.
Now, this is absolutely crucial,
the source claims.
This is not a genuine change of
heart.
It's not like a bunch of people
suddenly rediscovered a deep
love for their country.
No, Instead the essay argues
that this is a deliberate,
calculated, strategic move.
And this brings us right to the
core thesis of the essay, a
concept the author gives this
really memorable name, The Great
Patriotic Heist.
So what is the heist?
Well, the essay defines it as
this tactical takeover of
patriotism by what it calls
cultural elites.
And the motive?
According to the source, it's
all about controlling the story
of America, especially with its
250th anniversary just around
the corner.
The source breaks the whole
logic down into 3 pretty simple
steps.
First, there's a threat, the
possibility of Donald Trump
basically owning the narrative
of the America 250 celebration.
Second, there's a need you've
got to create a powerful counter
narrative to stop that.
And 3rd, the tool.
You take patriotism, a language
that had been kind of seated to
the right, and you rebrand it as
a progressive value.
This quote really captures the
feeling the essay is trying to
get across.
It's arguing this new patriotism
doesn't feel warm or real.
Instead it feels conditional,
almost like the country is being
told sure we can love you, but
only on these very specific pre
approved terms.
And this leads us to the central
conflict that the essay really
builds its entire argument on
this clash between two
fundamentally different ways of
thinking about love of country.
So the source draws this really
sharp contrast.
On one side, you've got what it
calls populist patriotism.
It's described as raw, direct,
maybe a little coarse, but
authentic.
On the other side, you have
managerial patriotism.
This is polished, strategic, and
feels more like a simulation
that's designed to control a
message you know, for your own
good.
What a metaphor, right?
The essay uses this image to
argue that this managed
patriotism is like an artificial
product.
It's engineer to taste like the
real thing, but it's missing
that essential kind of messy
substance.
Now, the essay talks a lot about
a specific group that it claims
is behind this whole thing.
It defines the managerial class
not as our elected officials,
but as the cultural gatekeepers
think, producers, academics,
bureaucrats, the people who
shape how we think and what we
talk about.
All right, so to give this
argument a bit more weight, the
source text zooms way out.
It argues that this battle over
what patriotism even means isn't
new at all.
It's actually a recurring theme
in American history.
This timeline from the source is
fascinating.
It shows how the very definition
of patriotism has shifted to
meet the needs of each era.
It started as loyalty to an idea
self rule back in 1776.
Then it became devotion to the
Union during the Civil War.
It turned into collective
sacrifice during World War 2,
and then this spontaneous pop
culture party in 1976.
After a short comeback post 911,
it kind of fell under suspicion.
The essay argues that today's
version is something totally
new, a tool for narrative
control.
This contrast is just so
critical to the essays whole
argument.
It holds up the 1976
bicentennial as this carnival of
belief, something that was
spontaneous grassroots from the
bottom up.
And then it predicts that the
upcoming 250th anniversary in
2026 is going to be the exact
opposite, a top down
professional focus grouped
marketing campaign.
Now, the source doesn't just
present one side of the story,
it actually includes a counter
argument.
And it frames this whole debate
as a question of theft versus,
well, legitimate ownership.
And here is that alternative
view.
This perspective basically
argues that every generation has
the right to reinterpret and
redefine the country's founding
principles.
So from this point of view, the
progressive embrace of
patriotism isn't some cynical
heist.
It's a totally legitimate act of
inheritance.
But despite acknowledging that
counter argument, the essay
comes down firmly on one side.
It's final moral judgement is
that what really matters most
isn't the political content of
patriotism, but it's
authenticity.
The source's closing argument is
basically that this heist is
doomed to fail, and not because
of some big political fight, but
because a performance of belief
just can't last forever.
It argues that mimicry
eventually gives itself away and
a nation founded by rebels isn't
going to be managed by life
coaches.
This is the essay's final,
really powerful claim about the
character of the country itself.
It argues that at its core,
America has this built in
preference for authenticity, no
matter how messy or ugly it
might be over some perfectly
crafted but totally false story.
And that's really where this
whole explainer of the essay
leaves us.
It boils the entire complicated
debate down to a single, really
provocative question.
Is true patriotism about
presenting A flawless, inspiring
narrative to the world?
Or is it about grappling with an
honest, complicated, and, yeah,
sometimes unflattering story?
The source has its answer, but
the question is 1 for all of us
to think about.